we're told that taylor opened a
restaurant the net value of the
restaurant in thousands of dollars two
months after its opening is modeled by v
of t is equal to two t squared minus
twenty t
taylor wants to know what the
restaurant's lowest net value will be
let me underline that
and when it will reach that value
so let's break it down step by step the
function which describes how the value
of the restaurant the net value of the
restaurant changes over time is right
over here if i were to graph it i can
see that the coefficient on the
quadratic term is positive so it's going
to be some form of upward opening
parabola i don't know exactly what it
looks like we can think about that in a
second and so it's going to have some
point right over here which really is
the vertex of this parabola where it's
going to hit its lowest net value and
that's going to happen at some time t if
you could imagine that this right over
here is the t axis so my first question
is is there some form is there some way
that i can rewrite this function
algebraically so it becomes very easy to
pick out this low point which is
essentially the vertex of this parabola
pause this video and think about that
all right so you could imagine the form
that i'm talking about is vertex form
where you can clearly spot the vertex
and the way we can do that is actually
by completing the square so the first
thing i will do is actually let me
factor out a 2 here because 2 is a
common factor of both of these terms so
v of t would be equal to 2 times t
squared
minus 10 t and i'm going to leave some
space because
completing the square which gets us to
vertex form is all about adding and
subtracting the same value on one side
so we're not actually changing the value
of that side but writing it in a way so
we have a
perfect square expression and then we're
probably going to add or subtract some
value out here
now how do we make this a perfect square
expression and if all if any of this
business about completing the square
looks unfamiliar to you i encourage you
to look up completing the square on khan
academy and review that but the way that
we complete the square is we look at
this first degree coefficient right over
here it's negative 10 and we say all
right well let's take half of that and
square it so half of negative 10 is
negative 5 and if we were to square it
that's 25. so if we add 25 right over
here then this is going to become a
perfect square expression and you can
see that it would be equivalent to this
entire thing if we add 25 like that is
going to be equivalent to
t
minus 5 squared just this part right
over here that's why we took half of
this and we squared it but as i alluded
to a few seconds ago a few minutes ago
you can't just willy-nilly add 25 to one
side or to one side of an equation like
this that will not that will make this
equality no longer true and in fact we
didn't just add 25 remember we have this
2 out here we added 2 times 25. you can
verify that if you redistribute the 2
you'd get 2t squared minus 20t
plus 50 plus 2 times 25. so in order to
make the equality or in order to allow
it to continue to be true we have to
subtract 50. so just to be clear this
isn't some kind of you know strange
thing i'm doing all i did is add 50 and
subtract 50. you're saying wait you
added 25 not 50. no look when i added 25
here it's in a parentheses and that
whole expression is multiplied by 2. so
i really did mult add 50 here so then i
subtract 50 here to get to what i
originally had and when you view it that
way
now v of t is going to be equal to 2
times this business which we already
established is t minus 5 squared and
then we have the
minus 50.
now why is this form useful this is
vertex form it's very easy to pick out
the vertex it's very easy to pick out
when the low point is the low point here
happens
when
this part is minimized and this part is
minimized think about you have two times
something squared so if you have
something squared it's going to hit its
lowest point when this something is zero
otherwise it's going to be a positive
value and so this part right over here
is going to be equal to zero when t is
equal to 5.
so
the lowest value is when t is equal to
5. let me do that in a different color i
don't want to reuse the colors too much
so if we say
v
of five
is going to be equal to
two
times
five
minus five
i'm trying to keep up with the colors
minus 5 squared minus 50. notice this
whole thing becomes 0 right over here so
v of 5 is equal to negative 50. that is
when we hit our low point in terms of
the net value of the restaurant
so t represents months so we hit our low
point we wrote our our we rewrote our
function in a form in vertex form so
it's easy to pick out this value and we
see that this low point happens at t
equals five which is at time five months
and then what is that lowest net value
well it's negative 50 and remember the
function gives us the net value in
thousands of dollars so it's nega it's a
negative 50
000 dollars is the lowest net value of
the restaurant and you might say how do
you have a negative value of something
well imagine if say the building is
worth fifty thousand dollars but you the
the restaurant owes a hundred thousand
dollars then it would have a negative
fifty thousand dollar net value